alors cette histoire intitulé les
aventures de monsieur tang a été écrite
et illustrée par les élèves de la classe
de ce2 cm1 au cours de l'année scolaire
2013-2014
eh bien je vais vous la raconter je vais
vous dire de quoi il s'agit qu'est ce
qui va arriver à monsieur tang qu'il va
rencontrer et ce qui va se passer dans
sa vie
sur une petite île de l'océan indien il
y à un quartier rempli de maisons tout
habité tout sauf une autour de cette
maison un jardin en friche abrite des
insectes par milliers s'il l'a que
monsieur tant que c'est installés dans
un terrier confortable
mais voici qu'arrive de nouveaux
habitants ceux ci possèdent deux chiens
féraux sein qui veulent capturer
insultant
monsieur tong tremble de peur devant
leurs dents pointues son coeur bat très
fort
impatient que qui passe dans le ciel la
paire soir non il peut pas le laisser
dans cet état il va devenir sous secours
qui descend rapidement pour secourir
monsieur temps
le paille-en-queue la tard par les
oreilles et s'envole au loin au dessus
des arbres et des chants il l'emmène
jusqu'à de falaise en bord de mer
c'est là que le paille-en-queue à son
nid
rendre service à son sauveur
monsieur temps propose d'aller chercher
de la nourriture pour les bébés
paille-en-queue mais il n'a pas réfléchi
qui ne sait pas ce que manger bébés
oiseaux
je t'embrasse larouche avec ses ongles
gratuit gratte
oshima solide et s'effritent et monsieur
temps donc tout en bas dans la mer
les vagues le soulève et le jette sur le
sable il se relève difficilement et se
dirige vers les finales des graines lui
tombe dessus ses yeux brûlent il voit
flou
il s'en va alors tout droit s'abriter
dans une poubelle renversée
pourquoi ne pas rester ici se dit il
j'aurais de quoi me nourrir et je suis
en sécurité
ce que monsieur temps n'a pas prévu
c'est que le camion poubelle va le
transporter dans une déchetterie non
loin de la ville
il ne se sent pas bien sûr ce pas
d'ordre et s'enfuit sur la route
bientôt ils arrivent en dit
le bruit des voitures lui casser les
oreilles les gens ne font pas attention
à lui et le bouscule évidente des coups
de pied
monsieur tanguay désespérée mais tout à
coup un pigeon se pose près de lui je
vois que tu n'es pas bien ici lui dit il
vient suis moi je connais un endroit qui
te plaira
les nouveaux amis traversent la ville
jusqu'à un chemin qui mène à la forêt je
te présente mon ami le pape en lui dit
le pigeon il va aider à trouver un abri
paisible où tu pourras tu installes et
moi je retourne en ville c'est là
qu'habite ma famille ma maison est là
bas
monsieur tang remercie le pichon et lui
promet de revenir lui rendre visite
bientôt le pape banques s'envolent et
guides monsieur temps entre les arts
soudain celui-ci aperçoit un trou rempli
de feuilles sèches
enfin un nid douillet où me reposer je
crois que le meilleur endroit pour moi
est ici c'est ici que je veux vivre pour
toujours
et si vous passez de temps en temps dans
la forêt vers maïdo vers tévelave
peut-être que vous allez rencontrer le
sultan et pensez vous que ses aventures
sont terminés et bien moi je n'en suis
pas si sûr